here we got this uh tweet from rep Eric
swalwell he's just breaking rep Byron
Donalds admits on the readout that
McCarthy is kicking me Adam Schiff and
ilhan off our committees purely out of
Vengeance yes it's out of Vengeance not
the fact that you slept at the Chinese
spy and she married her brother right
yeah that's thankful okay fair point but
I'll accept the Vengeance yeah yeah I'm
here for it it feels good either one is
fine with me man you're a piece of
garbage it's entertaining to see him
complains the amount of entitlements
power it's our counselor it's our what
do they call it committee whatever dude
it's the American people's committee
whatever prevents him from dropping
nukes on Americans that don't turn in
their AR-15s I'm fine we're having sex
with more Chinese spies Fang Fang had to
work really hard okay this is this is
the she really loses here more than
anyone else here how did this happen
Eric swallows on the with a house
intelligence committee and he's dating a
Chinese spy who's harvesting
intelligence
is it confirmed that she was withdrawing
extracting info from the guy do you know
I'm not entirely sure if it's confirmed
I mean but he was dating and having
sexual relations with the Chinese spy so
I can only imagine that I mean and Adam
Schiff lied all the time with the
intelligence and actually Adam's shift
should be removed from office just
because the of the the just because of
his neck just because he was going maybe
um just because he went to he was trying
to get people banned from Twitter he was
he was sending emails to Twitter trying
to infringe on people's first minute
right he released a private Citizen's
phone records yeah disgusting absolutely
disgusting creepy well he got a
journalist actually suspended and
permanently banned off of Twitter well
the guy that works for Real Clear
investigations right
on like it's unconscionable that people
that politicians behave like that and
it's extremely disheartening that we're
such a tribal Society right now that we
can't all say okay that's a violation of
liberal principles and we're you can't
be in a position of power anymore that
should be something that all Americans
say but that's not happening anymore
yeah oh the the mess the mistake is that
they say Twitter's private company so if
I walked into the Apple headquarters and
I started screaming they can kick me out
because it's a private company but it's
a different kind of Private Structure in
that it's a social network no it's not
because Adam Schiff is a rep as a as a
representative of the government getting
a hold of Twitter saying ban this person
that is prohibited by the First
Amendment so could could the government
cannot tell an intermediary to violate
someone's rights but could they say hey
Tim Cook at Apple don't let Ian Crossing
into the Apple headquarters could Adam
Schiff do that and then no Tim Cook's
like okay no you can't no because it's a
violation of your rights to go into the
Apple headquarters you you know they
they don't have the right
to tell someone else to violate your
right you have the right to move you
have the right to exchange in or to
engage in in uh Commerce the rights that
an individual has are infinite you have
the right to get up and leave you have
the right to go to the bathroom these
are all rights that you have you have
the because you're a free person so if
Tim Cook doesn't have a problem with you
going into his business and and you
don't have a problem and the government
says Tim Cook don't let that guy in your
in your business the government's saying
that what applies significant pressure
because it's the government the
government has the Monopoly on violence
so if they say that to Tim Cook and Tim
Cook says well you know I want him to
come in and buy stuff but the government
said I can't so I don't I can't let you
in Ian that's the government using their
influence on Tim Cook Tim Cook to
violate your rights and that is
expressly prohibited I don't know the
court the the court cases but I know
that the the Supreme Court has found
that the government cannot do the those
kind of the government can't use the
private sector as a means to suppress
your rights but do I have a right to go
into the Apple headquarters I don't
think that's it if Tim Cook doesn't want
you to or Tim you do have a right if if
uh building like the Apple Store well
she's the Apple headquarters if uh lose
the Apple Store as an example if it's
open to the public you do so like any
private company any little shop on Main
Street anything that anything that's a
public accommodation that allows people
to enter you can enter and they can give
you a warning to leave then they can
call the police the police give you a
warning then the police can remove you
or arrest you but if a corporation is
running a public-facing publicly
available business you have a right to
enter that business
if you remember a couple years ago I was
even saying these are not private
companies they're they're working
colluding together we're at government
working on the beheads of government
implementing a lot of their policies
that the government wants them to
implement and they parade themselves
around like look we're a private entity
we're a private business we could do
what we want no your tax dollars are
literally being used for FBI agents to
sit on social media to say you cannot
have speech here you cannot express your
opinion here and also when you look at
the the start of all of a lot of these
companies they they started with
connections not only to the government
but there was a lot of Grants there was
a lot of incentives that that allowed
them to become as powerful as they are
right now where they have a sort of
Monopoly on on the industry and they
dominate everyone where competitors
can't even compete with them because of
the unfair Advantage the government gave
them during the beginning of their start
uh which I think is important to note
here which also tells me this has
nothing to do with any private entity
here this is this is Aussie public one
let's talk about the yeah
the elephant in the room
the Civil War that collapsed and has
myocarditis if if we're entering this
period where in Congress they're doing a
Tit for Tat Vengeance that Nancy Pelosi
boots people off committees because she
doesn't like them so then McCarthy comes
in and Boots people off committees
because he's like okay this game we're
gonna play I mean we're heading to a
point where elections are determined by
who can collect the most abouts possible
not who actually has the best ideas
ballot Harvest and get the biggest
number and you're good to go and uh
Power will be wielded exclusively by
each side for their own benefit I don't
I I would I would expect the Republicans
to do exactly this I expect the
Republicans to impeach Joe Biden but of
course the Democrats started it and of
course they're not going to stop so if
we're at this point and the bifurcation
just keeps going where do we end up
the biggest split you've ever seen I
mean I think we're already at the point
where the country is divided like we've
never seen before but it's just going to
keep going and keep going but I've
always said that the right because the
right's always been the party of
defensive so it's nice to actually it's
refreshing to see that they're actually
taking the offensive at least somewhat
nowadays but I mean it's like Saul
Linsky the left literally operates off
of Rules for Radicals I mean that's how
they play you blame others of what
you're guilty of I mean the whole nine
yards so now that the ride is actually
doing it it's just going to keep going
and keep going until something finally
breaks and this is where I will agree
you know eventual Civil War or whatever
you want to word it as did you always
think that no no I mean over time I mean
one of the reasons why I got into the
industry was because I saw that the the
Republicans were just playing defensive
over and over again I was like okay we
need to fix this I mean I was an
activist before a journalist so I
painted baby lives matter murals outside
of abortion clinics pissed a lot of
people off but it was like a spin-off of
BLM right I was like they're doing it
I'll do it push back
um and then you know over time as I
became more radicalized or more rational
is what I would say uh I mean it just
kind of evolved my thought process and
now here we are I would agree that if if
it continues on the path that it's going
without intercession that we would see
some sort of physical conflict I mean
we've already seen physical conflict I
mean I mean you were right there when
Ashley Babbitt got shot yeah I mean
that's as physical as it gets I mean
that was government sanctioned murder I
mean the government's going to murder
people on National Television over and
over again and nobody says a thing I
mean there's no repercussions for it
they literally dropped all charges they
didn't actually investigate Michael bird
after the shooting I mean they did a
faux investigation and said oh yeah he's
cleared all the police violence that
took place on January 6 is cleared so
it's like how far can you continue to go
how how much government sanctioned
murder because that's what it was can
you actually tolerate until something
finally breaks did that change you
watching her get shot oh absolutely I
mean I think about it every single day
and I've been thankful to you know
really get close with her family her
family is like my family now Aaron
Babbitt Mickey they're absolutely
amazing people it's not what the media
says you know Ashley Babbitt wasn't some
you know disorganized terrorist that
wanted to go and take down the
government she was actually trying to
stop people within that room she punched
Zachary llama in the face and pulled him
backwards and then she went through the
window to try and stop this crowd but
you never hear about that wow he also
said that there were surveillance
footage in the capital showing the
incident that also can't be found yep
and then uh you almost told us something
about uh people being near her not being
prosecuted as well can you get into any
of this stuff yeah I can get into it all
um so the people that actually breach
the west side of the Capitol none of
them have been prosecuted I mean the
ones that actually they're on video
throwing two by fours through the window
breaking these and then you know they
hop in and then open the doors from the
inside to allow everybody else in um you
know there's one in particular that I
can think of off the top of my head he's
wearing all red has a red hat on and
they actually somehow ended up very
conveniently in the room with Ashley
Babbitt right as she was being shot
right around Ashley Babbitt as this took
place and they were on just like Ray
apps they were put on the FBI Wanted
list and then immediately almost
immediately taken off right after but
you never hear about any of them
you know what's going on
one could ask that and they probably
should but it's it's inconvenient to the
narrative and even if you do ask I mean
we've seen with what Ray Epps has uh
accomplished I mean he's literally on
video on January 5th multiple times
telling people to go into the capital uh
on multiple occasions and then January 6
doing the exact same thing I mean
there's even a video of him holding a
big uh Trump banner and actually pushing
it into police alongside other people
but you know Adam he's Adam kinsengers
and the committee's absolute darling and
they don't want to talk about and they
release the transcripts and it literally
says that hey I helped organize this and
he's on video doing so but you're not
allowed to talk about it and if you do
your label of conspiracy theories you
see there's transcripts of raps saying
that he helped organize January 6th yeah
I believe uh I don't know which
congressman that actually released it
originally um but I mean it's literally
in the transcripts that he is talking I
believe it's to his son I'm not 100 sure
on it but he organized it I mean he was
one of the organizers he said he
orchestrated it he is the person that I
followed to the Capitol while Trump was
speaking we arrived at the Capitol I
followed rayup's group I thought it was
suspicious he basically started rallying
people and saying hey 10 minutes we're
going to the Capitol we're going to the
Capitol and I'm sitting there like okay
this is really weird Trump supporters
going to the Capitol on Trump's very
last speech of the year his last speech
of his presidency to save America speech
is suspicious and you know I followed
them then the first barrier goes down
the second barrier goes down which
that's the famous video of Ray Epps you
know Whispering into Ryan samsel's ear
and then the barrier goes down
conveniently
um you know so he I was literally
alongside rayups he is the one that led
the first initial group on that west
side and breached those two barriers and
then something that isn't talked about
is after those first two barriers were
briefed you had about six officers
responsible for stopping hundreds of
thousands of people and there was a the
initial like you know I would call it
the riot zone or it was where the uh
they hold the inauguration every year
and they're the crowd of thousands of
people just started to form I mean
there's there's mothers there's children
people from all walks of life everyone's
just standing there I was already deep
in the crowd and it was peaceful for
about 20 to 30 minutes and then a
concussion grenade flies over my head
and explodes into the crowd and then it
just started to erupt so it literally it
was a police riot I would say thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time